welcome to this video this is a new part
of the calculation and tactics serious
yeah this is one of those where just
look at one position anthem yeah this is
a position that i will discuss but
certainly also position that you can
look at and try to solve em some of the
positions that i select en form for this
series we're just it's just one position
to look at not the tactics training
videos some of those are ready to be
honest very hard to solve they are
selected also for the beauty of it
because they're just very nice to look
at anthem and yeah try to yeah to do to
accept the challenge to solve them Bob
it's very difficult to do I think this
one is in fact possible to solve but not
easy at all this is from a game between
Victor Borge on and value meal off in
2003 plate and now Moscow yeah in fact
in the game um bolo gun played the move
Queen to be five yeah there was an
alternative a better move in a way I
helped you now because it's not Queen B
5 but what is the other move um I'm
going to also tell tell you some things
about the position that might help you
to get to the solution but if you just
want to look at it like that just the
position itself you might as well pause
the video here and have a look okay so
I'm not going to give you some features
of this position on some patterns that
might help you with them coming to the
solution if you look at the position
here you see that white is an exchange
down but as a compensation he has some
some huge assets here's the beep horn of
course very close to
to promotion he has some excellent they
placed night cm on f3 and g4 and those
nights totally dominate at the moment
the black queen on a tribe black has a
very unlucky position of his pieces the
Queen has no square really no square the
bishop is almost in tuned on g7 cannot
do much the rukon c6 is also unstable it
is unprotected and the rukon h8 is not
doing that much so white has a fantastic
compensation that that much is clear but
how actually um can we win this
technically directly win this Queen B 5
by the way what bulla bulla well played
ultimately also led to win out to some
advantages but here in this precise
position there is a force twin white can
definitely win by 4 cm the whole thing
is based on on those some factors that
are already mentioned that position of
black screen and stable position of the
rook also the B poem that is an
additional asset okay maybe you want to
look at it again with those kind of
hints as a backup so I'll be silent for
a couple of seconds again and then i'm
going to show you what really am what is
what solution is yeah the move that that
wins in this position is them maybe not
so a parent move Queen to d1 Queen to
the one is very very strong yeah why why
is this so strong there the real secret
behind the movies geometry the queen is
putting itself on the same diagonal as
the queen is on h5 and this is a very
very very tricky business that's coming
up now we look at this white has a very
substantial threat IAM white now
threatens to play 90
or yeah putting this knight on d4 which
it texts the rook 16 and this night move
also attacks the Queen by means of this
cover check Knight f6 check yeah so just
for argument's sake if black is some
let's say playing a nothing move yeah
let's say you place look at six or
something then we go here the rookies
detect and if it moves we will play this
and win the Queen very easy once you
have it on the board is easy yeah so 90
form is is a substantial threat what
happens if black takes the pawn the
Queen going away from be one has left
the pawn unprotected here it is easy we
give we get i get to d4 with the night
now a simple fork queen has to move
protecting the rook we take it and now
the final moves are actually easy we
have the check Queen comes back to be
one with check King moves and after b7
we will promote to a new queen very nice
so black cannot really take on f5 what
is the toughest defense and this is
actually really nice rook takes b6 is um
it's um what we need to check but also
what about this move Roxy form maybe
black is trying to counter sacrifice to
that white goes 92 yeah again
threatening Knight f6 and now black has
to give up the exchange takes Queen g5
and Queenie to wear the fantastic
position now widest threatening 94 here
almost strapping the Queen again and
still there's the beep on this is maybe
the defense that lets black him hang on
for the longest but the toughest one
really is rook takes p6 if we look at
this and also more logical what is why
doing now we are playing with the same
motif the discovered check why does
going 92 and this is now very neat we
threaten Knight f6 check and black has
no King move to attend to that yeah the
only King move is king g8 after which we
gonna I'd have six and he also cannot
protect the Queen ring so what is there
okay well Kim g8 I'm sorry of course now
the rook protects it but White has a way
to enforce this he can go 94 yeah have a
look at this this is really nice the
knight on e4 is also attacking here so
there is additional pressure on the pawn
black has no moves with the Queen rly
and no moves that help ya queen age 7 is
kind of pointless the squeem d8 and
queen d 8 is threatening anyway so what
should like do Luke a six yes to cover
have six all the time Queen d3y a note
there is this all protected and the rook
has to move rook b6 this route 28 so has
to go here and then we go Queen to d7
and this is the total domination the
rookies attacked from here did you get
lost from here as well
and black isn't zoosk vanya even loose
material now the Queen the rook it's
it's hopeless really funny so if we if
we go back what else is there there is
the stretch queen g5 okay after Queen g5
what is White's move here it's simple
actually nitey form and again everything
is working perfectly together the queen
is strap that cannot go here here here
everything is protected and really there
is only queen h5 back and white
ultimately will win the queen with
Knight f6 so that's a very nice little
tactical puzzle based on the geometrical
motif the screen on d1 the side this is
decisive move looking at age 5 and
setting up those threats especially
nicest that there are those motifs with
the knight on f3 coming away with the
tempo like this or after rook takes
actually with this move threatening here
possibly and threatening here or here so
it's a very nice booty with those pieces
perfectly yeah in perfect harmony this
is always very nice i think if you we
have this kind of perfect coordination
of forces which is the case here with
with white it also shows that a bad
position of the Queen very often is
enough to lose you the game and this is
really a clear case where black is
basically playing without his strongest
piece and it's however quite nice to see
that white can make use of it so quickly
with Queen D one after that black really
has no defense yeah I hope you enjoyed
this little puzzle I think it said so
it's very nice it's very it's a very
visual kind of
with the Queen on this this funny
diagonal and leading to a loss yeah I
hope you enjoyed it thanks for watching